all right I'm Scott Butterworth here
with Mike maja ready to talk to you
about watchdogs to Ubisoft has finally
confirmed that it is a real thing it is
happening is coming out this year they
actually did a live stream just earlier
today but Mike I know you just got back
from Montreal where you actually got to
see the game in person right so they
showed us all this stuff that they show
this morning I didn't get the plane T
but I did get to interview like the lead
producer the director or the lead
designer and the lead writer and they
were kind of shedding light on a lot of
the different aspects that we saw in the
trailers the biggest changes it least in
my mind the fact that it's now set not
in Chicago but in the Bay Area and that
we have a new hero as well so how much
of the new world did you actually see so
they showed us the new main character
Marcus he's a hacker like an Oakland
native and his parents were activists
and he got pushed out from the
gentrification in San Francisco sees
police brutality sees you know racial
profiling and kind of leads him to want
to impact society in a meaningful way
and he's a gifted hacker and then you
know you come in from San Francisco and
this big this game world is two times
the size of the Chicago of the first
watchdogs according to the director of
watchdogs two it's also much more
interactive they're calling it very
hackable as opposed to the first one
every single car you can remote hack
like back into people or drive shipments
of something into the bay every phone is
hackable it's not just certain people so
you can still see those little tidbits
of information which I really like from
the first game but you also can do this
Mass hack where everybody's phone
vibrates for a distraction when you're
maybe trying to escape or something
that's awesome and are the rest of
mechanics pretty similar as well can you
still like hijack cars and shoot and all
that kind of stuff as well
yeah so they also like they want to
refine all the ones I had in the first
game so the driving which a lot of
people complain about in neogaf and lead
producer Dominic was telling me that he
went through all those forums and
driving was the first thing it's much
more arcadey now and that's not like to
say it's not gonna feel so realistic but
it's more like to facilitate fun where
the first one was kind of more of a
simulator it's kind of clunky and didn't
feel that great when you're exploring
yeah they also have ways you can run
into other people right there's these
cooperative elements like almost like
the division with chibi Safa obviously
also worked on you run into other
players in the world and you can play
through the entire game and multiplayer
co-op if you wanted to you both can
explore the city and for the cities I
guess and you'll find dedsec logs dedsec
being the group of you're part of
they're like anonymous you're gaining
the metagame is you're gaining followers
and then the bigger you get the bigger
the challenges you're facing you
actually like kind of coming up against
political and geographical kind of
conflicts have been plaguing the area
and you're actually taking on bigger
things and just like taking over and
advertising
space or you know like graffiti and
whatnot gotcha so it's not so much like
the very personal revenge story of aiden
pearce that seems to be sort of a
broader sort of more focused on social
and justices and things of that nature
right so that like the vibe of it itself
with Marcus feels different he's more of
a team player he's also a very self-made
he's his main weapon is a billiard ball
with a hole through it that a rope is
tied through so you used like a modder
like a makeshift morningstar he also has
a quadcopter like scout drone that can
kind of see different areas of the city
he's a little remote control like jumper
they're calling it's just like a car
that can navigate through them maybe
you'll get upgrades to have explosives
on or something yeah I guess would be
some kind of progression system because
there was in the first game yeah there's
a full RPG progression system that'll
keep you like getting new skills and
abilities again I haven't played it I
don't know how I need is gonna be
implemented but it's all looking really
promising and I'm excited for it because
the first game kind of had you a lot of
these cool ideas conceptually but I
didn't really think many of them came to
fruition and Chicago felt kind of
lifeless whereas they think you know
they're making a concerted effort to
make the Bay Area feel alive and vibrant
and kind of filled with people and
things to do and like reasons to explore
so the game comes out November 15th this
year there's no Assassin's Creed as you
mentioned so this is like their you know
their flagship title for the year and
it's really likely we're gonna see more
of it next week at e3 given that you
know they're now officially talking
about the game right yeah they're
definitely they're gonna show off a demo
and everything they've told us so we'll
be set to see more of that and see how
the game kind of unfolds in terms of
gameplay yeah all right well awesome
thanks Mike and yeah everybody stay
tuned come back to gamespot.com next
week where we will have more information
about watchdogs too